♪ ♪
[horn blares]
- What do you think?
- Slams okay.
- Mm-hmm.
- Want to give it a test drive?
- Yeah.
Seats are comfy.
- It's nice.
- You guys done
jerking each other off?
- You see jizz everywhere, Lea?
- Yeah, Lea, if we were
jerking each other off,
there'd be jizz everywhere.
- I'll put in our bid.
- This is great.
We can get twice as much
work done with this van.
- Absolutely.
We can work twice as hard.
- Work ourselves
into the ground
until we blow our brains out
like Sebastian's dad.
- Or go insane like my dad.
- Mm-hmm.
Well,
let's go get this work van
for work.
- Let's do it.
[funk music]
- ♪ Hey, TD! ♪
- ♪ Yeah, yeah! ♪
- ♪ I need some loving, baby ♪
- ♪ You need what now? ♪
♪ Some loving, some loving,
some loving ♪
- ♪ Huh! Oh, yeah! ♪
- ♪ [screams] ♪
- ♪ Oh, this loving, baby ♪
- ♪ You need loving ♪
♪ Yeah, yeah ♪
- ♪ Oh, loving, loving ♪
- ♪ You need some loving
loving ♪
- ♪ So good, baby ♪
- ♪ I got to tell you, baby ♪
- ♪ What you gonna tell me? ♪
- ♪ What you got to do, yeah ♪
- ♪ What I got to do, baby? ♪
- ♪ Just listen to the song
yeah ♪
[music fades out]
- Assholes.